the jurgen experience who is the
who's the unbiased journalist who's the
one that we trust for information
it used to be the new york times the new
york times should be like brutally
honest about basically everything
and now you read something in the new
york times like we did when oh it's the
new york times though
yeah like that's a weird shift that's
happened in the last 10 years like
less yeah but right well yeah i mean
it's definitely been like exposed in the
last 10 years but i think that
truthfully i
i think it's kind of a silver lining
that at least people are starting to be
aware of that
and people are starting to go like okay
i know that these institutions are not
to be trusted
because truthfully speaking they got you
know
it's like i was saying to you before uh
we started where it's like for for all
the that people give alex jones
he got all of the biggest stories right
over the last 20 years and i'm not
saying he didn't get anything wrong
but really really big things like should
we go to war in iraq
yeah should we bail out bankers should
all of this he called these as lies and
corruption right away
and the new york times was selling all
of these i mean they sold the war in
iraq and so
it's to me it's not the worst thing in
the world if people at least recognize
that these institutions are completely
compromised and i
i agree with you that there is a role
for objective journalism but i would at
least accept
if they were like hey listen we think
like what you just said we think we have
this platform and we need to use this
to get donald trump not elected at least
be honest with that
don't me and tell me we're just
doing objective news
and every single story is about how
donald trump is you know needs to they
don't even address it they don't say
they're doing
objective news anymore they just do
their thing well they call other news
fake news
so they'll say the new york times
doesn't well the new york times may not
but i'm speaking in the corporate press
in general right they'll say like well
there's fake news out on the internet
and even the new york times has done
stories about how
social media companies need to do more
to you know
fake news on the internet and things
like that but they're talking about like
super hardcore q and
on type aren't they well kind of i
mean it starts with that
and then they'll use that as an example
but then usually they also go to other
things like look this uh
this this new york post story about
hunter biden's laptop
was called fake news from the day it
came out to the point that not only
would all of the corporate press not
report on that
but that social media companies were
banning the link and twitter froze
the new york post's twitter account one
of the cnn journalists
on twitter called it russian
disinformation yes this a bunch of
people called it russian disinformation
i wonder if it was russian
disinformation
the the photo of the girl giving him a
foot job
yes was that russian that was all she
was russian and the foot was russian
it was a russian footjob what happened
to that
i kind of lost track of what was
happening with the laptop but they'd
like
have they shared information of it rudy
giuliani sold it on ebay
made a killing i don't know this this is
the thing that's going on there's almost
like too much information is coming at
us
well look the it's basically been
verified that this was hunter biden's
laptop i mean with within any reasonable
standard for for a journalist to verify
something i mean number one
the bidens didn't deny it like nobody
actually came out and denied that this
was
they had his signature at the repair
shop which they matched up to his
signature
they've had other people on the email
chains confirm that they were these were
emails between them and hunter biden
so it's been pretty reasonably kind of
verified that this was hunter biden
now i don't know about the crazier
accusations that were made there
i mean rudy giuliani said that there
were pictures of underage girls and
stuff like that i don't know
if that's true or not but rudy giuliani
did turn it over to the delaware police
that is true because the delaware a
spokesman for the attorney general
said that they received the laptop and
that they sent it to the fbi
now i don't know why they would he would
turn this over claiming this stuff was
on there
and then they would send this to the fbi
if there wasn't something
but i don't know i don't but what you do
know right is that
this was a story where they had these
emails about hunter biden who is very
clearly a swamp creature
who was selling his father's name
to raken money from foreign companies
now truth be told that's a kind of
run-of-the-mill scandal as far as
politics going
it's normal every senator's kid family
wife they all do stuff like this all the
time it's a corrupt
swamp you know but it's a story
nonetheless
it may not be the but to but to just
make the conscious decision
that we are a few weeks out from a
presidential election this can harm
biden and therefore we're not mentioning
it we're not covering it
we're not trying to debunk this to a
bunch of people we are trying to make
sure people never get their eyes on this
well i think they felt the heat they
felt the heat from
2016 from the hillary clinton email
debate
you know whether or not she should have
deleted those emails and that the fact
that
comey then opens up the investigation
again in the middle of the campaign
and that was basically what a lot even
though she won the popular vote
a lot of people felt like that was that
was a bad move
and so this year they said we're going
to do everything we can to get rid of
donald trump again
they become activists instead of just
journalists yeah
that's it's tricky well that's 100
percent what happened i mean they felt
in a way that
they were responsible for donald trump
winning
ex hunter biden associates records don't
show
proof of biden business relationship
amid
unanswered questions episodes of the joe
rogan experience are now
free on spotify that's right they're
free
from september 1st to december 1st
they're going to be available everywhere
but after december 1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love bubba